hola bienvenido a programación si nunca
antes has aprendido a programar puede
que te estés preguntando qué es en
realidad la programación bueno cuando
escribimos un programa le estamos dando
a la computadora una serie de comandos
que se asemejan a una forma rara del
inglés puedes pensar en la computadora
como si fuera un perro muy obediente
escuchando las órdenes y haciendo todo
lo que le digas que haga entonces qué es
lo interesante de la programación bueno
eso en realidad depende de lo que tú
pienses que es interesante porque
resulta que puedes usar la programación
para casi cualquier cosa
los programas controlan robots que
pueden cuidar pacientes y mis favoritos
robots que pueden recorrer marte y
buscar agua en la superficie los
programas ayudan a los coches de auto
conducción a saber en donde girar lo que
es muy importante
los programas ayudan a los doctores a
curar enfermedades procesando una enorme
cantidad de datos médicos los programas
pueden ser juegos muy divertidos como
andrew jones angry birds minecraft los
programas hacen posible que pixar
desarrolle sus impresionantes películas
animadas 3d
y que películas como harry potter tengan
tan buenos efectos especiales cuál es tu
película favorita apuesto a que se hizo
con una computadora hay programas detrás
de las páginas web y aplicaciones que
usas todo el tiempo como google maps
wikipedia y youtube y por supuesto en la
que estás ahora mismo khan academy aquí
en can academy vas a aprender cómo
escribir programas en javascript para
hacer dibujos animaciones y juegos y eso
será un buen comienzo para crear
cualquier cosa que imagines en tu mente
o sea que puede ser difícil ver como un
programa de dibujo se relaciona con
programas para robots o para curar
enfermedades pero lo creas o no los
mismos conceptos básicos son usados por
casi cada programador en cada programa
una vez que aprendas cómo programar en
javascript serás capaz de aprender otros
lenguajes de programación mucho más
fácilmente ahora solo tienes que
continuar